OG you held this Blazers team to just 84
points tonight defensively what stood
out to you uh we were just really
connected uh we were flying around
getting stops communicating just
rebounding and pushing connected on the
other end too six different Knicks in
double figures how would you describe
the flow of the offense that we're
seeing in this five-game win streak just
fighting the open man and everyone
shooting with confidence and being
aggressive 16 points for you in that
first quarter does it feel like things
are kind of clicking as you're making
your way on this team yeah I think it's
getting better and better every game OG
you got the OG chance from the garden
crowd for the first time tonight this
place is so magical what was it like to
get that for the first time from these
fans oh yeah it was really cool you know
it was really cool thanks o